Today we'll be speaking with doctor Jamil Zaki on empathy and emotion doctors.
Aki is an assistant professor of psychology at Stanford University.
His research examines the neural bases of social cognition and behavior.
In other words,
how do people come to understand each other and decide to behave towards each
other?
So this work spans a number of domains including empathy,
theory of mind,
social influence,
and prosocial behavior.
Doctors oc,
he received his BA in cognitive neuroscience from Boston University and his phd
in psychology from Columbia University after which she conducted postdoctoral
research on altruism and prosocial behavior at the Harvard Center for Brain
Science.
He's received research and teaching awards from Society for Personality and
Social Psychology,
the cognitive neuroscience society,
the Society for neuroscience,
the American psychological association,
the association for Psychological Science,
autism speaks as well as Harvard University.
So I now turn to a very special experts in emotion interview with one of the
most empathic people that I know,
which is doctor Jamil Zaki speaking with us on empathy and emotion.
So welcome Jamil.
Thanks for being with us today.
Thanks a lot for having me.
So I'd love to start out just by asking you a little bit about what got you
first interested in emotion,
sort of where did it all start for you?
Yeah,
I mean,
um,
so for me,
uh,
I guess it's a little bit of a personal story actually because I got interested
in empathy,
uh,
through my grandmother,
my mother's mother.
My mom was born and raised in Peru.
Um,
and my grandmother lived there for most of her life,
but lived with,
uh,
with me while I was growing up.
And of course there are lots of very empathic people in the u s but Peru is a
collectivistic culture.
And,
um,
and my grandmother,
it was an incredibly collective is the person.
And I was always struck by how her emotional life seem to center not around what
happened to her,
but around the,
uh,
failures,
successes,
um,
happiness and pain of those around her.
And she's a,
she was the most empathetic person I ever knew.
Um,
so she got me interested in this subject and it was only many years later that,
uh,
that I discovered you could study empathy through psychology and neuroscience.
Well that's a beautiful story.
And from what I hear and what I know about you to,
you're one of the most empathic people out there as well.
Well thank you.
So I want to ask you some questions then about your work on empathy.
So we can all relate to these feelings of empathy,
those maybe we have for other people like,
like our grandmas or even animals for those us who have pets.
But defining what empathy is seems to be a bit tricky.
So as an expert in empathy,
I was wondering if you could tell us a bit about what do you see as the sort of
key or essential ingredients that make up empathy?
Yeah,
I mean,
that's a great question and I think that empathy is such a complex,
multifaceted phenomenon at over the years.
Uh,
it's come up,
it's,
it's been described,
there are many different definition by many different scientists.
And so,
um,
in my work,
instead of trying to stump for one definition or another,
I've tried to put a bunch of them together and I see they're really being three
key ingredients to what I would consider the experience of empathy.
Um,
so one is what you could consider a very emotional response to someone sort of
sharing their joy or pain,
uh,
or the experience,
I would call this something like a Bill Clinton effect,
right?
Because Clinton is famous for saying that he felt the pain of other people
around him.
Uh,
another piece to empathy might be something that's very much more cognitive.
So understanding what other people are feeling and where those feelings come
from.
This is sometimes been called a what's in this theory of mind.
Uh,
and then a third might be considered a motivational piece.
So given that I understand what you're feeling and share what you're feeling,
do I have a motivation or desire to change?
What's your feeling?
Uh,
and make it better,
sort of alleviate your suffering or increase the positive ethic that you're
experiencing.
And what's interesting is that these different pieces of empathy can sometimes
split apart,
right?
So for instance,
um,
if you see someone else who's experienced this in lots of pain,
let's say it has had an accident,
you might share that pain through something that we would call it emotional
contagion.
You might feel very distressed yourself,
but your response to that distress might not be to help that person.
It might be to get out of there as soon as you can because you really don't
enjoy that feeling of distress that you have because of that person.
Similarly,
psychopaths for instance,
are sometimes great at understanding other people,
uh,
but far from using that understanding to share other people's aspect or help
them,
they off use it to manipulate and even harm others.
So I think this really suggests that these key ingredients to empathy,
although they're related,
can also be distinct.
That's just,
it's really interesting to just realize how multifaceted empathy really is.
I mean,
that then begs the question of,
well,
how is empathy different from these other kind of ideas that we have in our
minds of sympathy or pity?
Is it a,
is it distinct from those,
would you say?
I think that,
um,
I think that sympathy and pity,
uh,
and,
and you know,
uh,
sharing people's pain,
um,
all of these kind of words capture that.
There's this sort of different descriptions of what I would think of as pieces
of but be right.
The experience of pity for instance,
is one where you see someone else's suffering you might feel for them,
but you don't share their,
their emotions.
It's,
it's,
it's very easy to kind of pity someone without really kind of,
uh,
entering into the emotion that they're experiencing.
And I think critically,
a lot of the emotions can variably,
uh,
affect the way that we actually choose to help others.
Right?
So a sense of pity might not be the most useful feeling if you really want,
I want to encourage people to go out and help others.
That's really helpful.
Jamil.
And what's,
what's neat about you've done an empathy is not just sort of unpack the
different component parts of empathy,
but you've also,
you know,
shed some really exciting discoveries into the neural basis of empathy.
And I was just wondering,
what do you think are some of the most exciting discoveries that we know right
now about the brain and its ability to help kind of give rise to this capacity
for empathy?
Yeah,
I mean,
I think,
uh,
the science and the neuro science of empathy in particular has exploded over the
last 10 or 15 years.
It's a really exciting time to be in the field.
I mean,
a lot of the great work in this area has really started out by confirming that
these different pieces of empathy are in fact separate.
So for instance,
there's very famous work that,
that,
uh,
you and,
and many of your viewers will probably have heard of on so called mirror
neurons,
right?
These are neurons that,
uh,
that sort of come online and,
and in,
in,
in human's brain areas that come online,
both when you,
uh,
perform an action and when you view someone else performing that same action and
they're similarly,
uh,
regions in the brain that respond both when you experience pain and see someone
else in pain,
when you experienced reward and see someone else experienced reward.
Uh,
and so forth.
And these,
I think really this kind of quality of the brain,
which I could call it neuro residents for instance,
um,
uh,
suggest that this vicarious components,
empathy is really strongly rooted in,
in that particular system of brain regions.
By contrast,
a neuroimaging studies of theory of mind,
for instance.
Sure,
totally different pattern of brain activity,
right?
These are regions of the brain that such as the medial prefrontal cortex and
posterior singular,
without getting into too much detail,
these are all some of the brain that are most active when we're at rest,
they seem to be involved in kind of figuring out what it is that other people
are feeling.
Uh,
and,
and the really interesting thing about these two systems is that not only are
they different in space right there in different parts of your brain,
but in fact,
uh,
for instance,
damage to one of these systems can affect an affective empathy or emotional
empathy without changing cognitive empathy and vice a versa.
Right?
So there's some real evidence here that these components of empathy are
distinct,
not only at the psychological level,
but also at the level of the brain.
Um,
I think that for me,
some of the most exciting work that's happening now focuses not on separating
these two systems,
but rather on seeing how they come together.
So oftentimes when we empathize with someone,
it's not on the basis of something simple,
like just seeing them in pain or knowing what it is that they're feeling.
It's a complex combination of cues.
I was think of a,
for instance,
gold medal winners,
right?
So you see someone who just won the gold medal,
and if you didn't know that they had won the gold medal,
you think that they were totally miserable,
right?
These people are often crying hysterically.
They seem really upset if anything,
but you know,
based on context that in fact you should interpret their facial expressions.
They're crying is tears of joy,
not of sorrow.
And,
and so I think that that now it is,
uh,
researchers have started to focus on how the neural systems that are involved in
processing cues like facial expressions combined with the neuro systems that
focus on understanding complex contextual information to come up to kind of put
the pieces together and come up with our full empathic response to these
complicated social situations.
And that's really interesting because you're talking about just how these
complicated social systems require this sort of advanced understanding of key
contextual cues.
And when you think about the work,
both neuro neuroscience work as well as maybe if you want to speak to behavioral
work,
do you think this kind of work really suggests that empathy is a uniquely human
capacity?
Oh,
that's a great question.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think that over over the last,
well,
I mean at least probably 30 years,
scientists have debated sort of how much do a other animals,
especially nonhuman primates,
uh,
feel empathy and understand,
what other members of their species are experiencing.
And I think that this work has sort of taken on two different,
uh,
two different dimensions.
One is really impressing us with how,
uh,
how,
how much of the pieces of empathy other animals appear capable of experiencing.
And the second is to suggest that even though,
uh,
other animals can experience some of these qualities,
they probably don't reach the level of,
uh,
of what we would consider sort of the,
the full fledged complexity of,
of human empathy.
So for instance,
on the one hand,
there's lots of evidence that chimpanzees,
um,
can do a really impressive job of understanding what other members of their
species and humans can,
can see what they,
what they know,
what they believe,
how they intend to act,
and so forth.
Uh,
and,
uh,
on,
on the kind of line of emotional empathy,
there's been really impressive work over the last five years or so demonstrating
that,
um,
that even mice appeared to feel or share the pain of other members of their
species.
Uh,
one of my favorite studies in this direction been last year at the University of
Chicago.
And research has found that rats,
we're not only motivated to help a fellow rat who is trapped by some kind of
cage like apparatus,
they even gave up chocolate in order to help the other at.
And then after helping the wrath,
they gave up some of the chocolate to share with that other member of their
species.
I mean this is sort of,
it's,
it's cute,
but it's also a,
it's also really interesting because it suggests that these animals,
not even nonhuman primates,
but even rodents experience empathy at levels that probably,
uh,
people might not suspect.
On the other hand,
there's very little evidence that rats actually understand the states of,
of their,
uh,
of their conspecifics.
And in fact there's no clear kind of a homologous or,
or analogous brain region,
uh,
in,
in rats and mice,
uh,
that would map onto the brain regions that we use to understand each other.
Uh,
and,
and even non human primates,
although they might be able to understand at some of what,
uh,
what other members of their species in 10,
they certainly not,
they don't appear as motivated to help other members of their species as we do.
Do you think this suggests something about there being different shades or
levels of empathy across different species?
Yeah,
I do.
Uh,
I do think,
um,
I basically think again,
if you,
if you think of empathy as sort of this,
uh,
rich construct and you only call something empathy when it involves all three of
the pieces about which we've been talking.
I think that what this works suggests is that nonhuman animals have the capacity
to feel one piece or another piece or sometimes even two of these pieces,
but rarely if ever.
Uh,
and,
and I would say that there was no real evidence that they,
that they experience is kind of what I would again called full fledged,
uh,
empathy in terms of this rich multifaceted constructs.
No,
that's helpful.
So if we kind of take a step back and sort of think about what might be the
broad or kind of public health consequences of trying to understand and foster
greater empathy,
would we,
what would that have,
you know,
towards the building?
Maybe a more compassionate society?
Hmm.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
if,
if I could just put in a plug,
uh,
if,
your viewers have,
have not seen the book that they probably have a by Steve Pinker,
the better angels of our nature.
It's,
it's just,
it's a fantastic book,
uh,
about really a profound but simple point,
which is that over the centuries I have,
society has become reliably more violent or less violent.
We think of ourselves as maybe living in this really violent,
destructive time.
But in fact,
pinker really clearly lays out the idea that,
that we live in an incredibly peaceful circumstances compared to any other
moment in,
in,
in our species' history.
Uh,
and our society's history.
And,
and he suggests,
and,
and I'm,
I'm on board with this,
that maybe this has to do with an expansion or where an expansion in our
empathy,
a change in the way that we think of and relate to other people's suffering,
right?
I mean,
we might be much more averse to human suffering now than we were centuries ago.
and I think that what makes this profound to me as an empathy researcher is when
you get into this field,
the,
one of the first questions that you ask yourself and the other people ask you,
is,
is empathy a fixed quality?
Is it,
is it something that you're born with a certain level of empathy and that's all
you're going to have for your entire life at a broader level.
Does our society have a fixed level of empathy that can never change?
I think increasingly is evidence that empathy can be changed,
right?
So,
um,
it can be changed in the short term by things like perspective taking
interventions,
right?
Having people really,
uh,
walk a mile in someone else's shoes,
for instance.
Right?
And there are all sorts of psychological interventions that get people to
seriously consider the points of view of others,
uh,
and demonstrate that this helps not only helps people feel motivated to act more
altruistically,
for instance,
towards members of their own group,
but can even sort of help to dissolve some of the boundaries between groups,
for instance,
between political parties or different nations.
Right.
And this is sort of a work this on the cusp of being more applicable.
Um,
similarly in the medium term,
there are lots of compassion meditation interventions that people are using now.
Uh,
and there's great evidence just emerging,
uh,
over the last few years that these types of meditation can alter people's
prosocial behavior,
their preferences for helping other people as well as some of the brain activity
that underlies certain forms of empathy.
So I hope that researchers in the coming year is,
uh,
take a hard look at how we can really expand these interventions,
both to make them broader.
So I like the idea of transits online interventions that can reach thousands of
people as opposed to just a few people and also more long term.
Are there things that we can do to change people's levels of empathy,
not just over the course of hours,
but over the course of months or even years.
I think that this could have huge policy implications both in helping,
uh,
again,
dissolve the boundaries between groups of people that really harm us as a
society and also helping to strengthen the relationships,
uh,
that keep us healthy as individuals.
Yeah.
So you talked about sort of your hopes and visions for the coming years.
Where do you see this field,
uh,
headed in the years to come,
sort of what would you see as being on the horizon?
Yeah,
I mean,
I think,
um,
you know,
the future of empathy research and emotion research more broadly to me,
um,
is,
is interesting because I see the field going in two really different directions.
One is towards a very fine grained assessment of emotion and empathy.
So sort of a,
there were lots of new computational and math models of,
of emotion.
And there are a lot of great tools from Matt from,
ah,
please,
like computer science and economics that are allowing us to really assess how
events affect our emotional experiences,
um,
in ways that we never could before.
And then the second direction is actually the opposite one towards the study of
more complex and naturalistic emotions,
right?
A lot of emotion research and especially empathy research has focused on things
like looking at other people's faces.
Um,
but really like,
like with the gold medal winner that we were talking about earlier,
oftentimes empathy and emotion in general,
um,
takes place in much more complex situations.
And I think that now research has a focusing on studying how emotion and empathy
unfold,
uh,
in more kind of,
if you will,
real life circumstances.
So what would you say then for students who are thinking of embarking in this
study of emotion generally and maybe empathy specifically,
what advice would you have for students?
Yeah.
You know,
I think it's,
it's just,
it's got to be the old Wayne Gretzky quote,
uh,
that you've got to skate not to where the puck is,
but where it's going to be.
Right.
Um,
emotion research is relatively young.
Uh,
it changes all the time.
and I think that for students of,
of emotion,
it's important not just to really enjoy and,
and,
and sort of think about the work that people are doing now and have done,
but really look for the gaps that I think about,
uh,
what the next steps are,
that have yet to be taken,
sort of the undiscovered country,
if you will.
Undiscovered country of,
of emotion.
That's right.
Well,
thanks for speaking with us today to meal.
Um,
this concludes our experts in emotion interview series with Doctor Jamil Zaki
from Stanford University.